un procès qui se poursuit alors que
hollywood s'empare pour la première fois
du 11 septembre
le premier film la première fiction sur
le sujet vient d'être projeté au
festival de new york united 93 c'est son
titre raconte la révolte des passagers
dans l'un des vols détournés des
passagers qui avaient tenté de reprendre
le contrôle de l'appareil avant qu'il ne
s'écrase en pennsylvanie correspondance
à landshut c'est la scène clé la scène
de la rébellion
informés grâce à des téléphones
portables de ce qui se passait à new
york et washington
des passagers du vol united 93 du 11
septembre 2001 montrent un complot dans
le complot pour tenter de reprendre le
contrôle de l'avion et d'éviter la
destruction du capitole l'objectif des
pirates de lège ses quarante hommes et
femmes sont en passe de devenir des
héros mythiques au même titre que les
défenseurs de fort alamo
en 1836 et le film qui a ouvert hier
soir le festival de new york créé par
robert de niro contribuer à ce phénomène
c'est une histoire qui célèbre et
courage et sacrifice et nous sommes
fiers d'ouvrir le festival avec les
familles de victimes ont été associés
dès le départ à l'élaboration et au
tournage du film
n'empêche que l'évocation des derniers
instants de proches est toujours
difficile
c'est très douloureux pour moi maxime
était si cher c'était le grand amour de
m même si c'est difficile
émotionnellement de voir un tel film
c'est important que les gens sachent
par une curieuse coïncidence un court
extrait de la boîte noire du vol 93 a
été rendu public il ya quelques jours au
cours du procès moussaoui
c'est le chef des pirates de l'air qui
parle
seulement ça ça n'était pas du cinéma et
le boeing s'est bien écrasés dans cette
clairière de pennsylvanie mais grâce au
courage de ces 33 passagers
le capitole est toujours de beaux
retours entre